dynamic programming at ease with
grammars algebras products i'm very
happy to be here and talk about dynamic
programming today
but first of all why why do we want to
do dynamic programming we want to do
this to solve combinatorial optimization
problems
these problems have a combinatorial part
that means we have some counting to do
we have to enumerate all possible
solutions of a recursive kind of problem
and then we have the optimization part
so we have to find a desired solution
whatever desire it means for us it could
be that we want the maximum of some
score or something like that
examples for these kind of problems
would be the boggle problem where you
are given a grid of letters characters
let's say a 4x4 grid and you have a
dictionary of words that you're supposed
to find in there and you can have all
these movements on the grid there they
are allowed but you just cannot return
to where you came from so how do you
enumerate these words in an optimal way
another really nice example is the money
changing problem i think it's the
smallest problem that i could find that
can be solved by dynamic programming
that's why we're going to use it as an
example so imagine you have an amount of
money let's say five dollars and you
have some coins let's say you have one
dollar three dollar and four dollar how
can you decompose this value of money
um
another example that we use quite often
in bioinformatics
text or sequence alignment
that we use to see how similar sequences
are so we would use this for
biosequences so for example for dna so
how similar is my dna to the dna of a
mouse
and another example from bioinformatics
would be rna structure prediction so the
prediction of the structure of a
molecule which can form base pairs when
it's folding back onto
itself um but let's get started with
some classical dynamic programming
um
i don't know how many of you did some
dynamic programming before maybe you
want to raise your hand
oh quite a few that's good but we're
going through it like really really
quickly
so if i want to solve a dynamic
programming problem and i go up my
algorithms book it will tell me you have
to do these four steps to solve it so if
you think about the money changing
problem and as i said
we have our coins here so we have one
three and four dollars and we have this
amount of money um five um
first of all the first step that my
algorithms book set is characterize the
structure of an optimal solution so if i
want to decompose this number five
my optimal solution would be a sum right
and it would be a sum that's composed of
these values of the coins one three and
four so it's some weighted kind of sum
um
okay the second step recursively define
the value of an optimal solution
how do we do that recursively define it
we do that with something that we also
call recurrences so these are equations
that have the same term reoccurring on
the right side so there's some recursive
definition going on and for our money
changing problem this would be the
recurrence so we could define the n in
terms of some smaller sub problems and
because we want to have a sum
uh we could say if we just if we just
subtract one of the coins so for example
we subtract minus one or minus three or
minus four um
we would get a smaller sub problem so we
would have a smaller sum that we then
have to decompose and if we are at 0 we
are done this is our base case because 0
we cannot decompose it further
ok the next step would be
to compute the value of an optimal
solution so
let's keep in mind we want to count the
ways how to
how to decompose the five dollars how
many ways are there and we usually in
dynamic programming you just we do this
with a table and we do this in a
bottom-up fashion so here we can have
our table and the value n it goes up to
5 because this is the sum we want to
decompose this is the final problem we
want to solve
and then for a d
we are going to uh
we are going to write down the solution
for that particular sum
so uh if we want to fill this table we
can follow these arrows so i made these
arrows to make it make it a bit easier
so for the one dollars we just have
steps of one so it's kind of easy for
the three dollars we are going from
n like and then n is zero to n three and
from one to four and so on and then for
the four dollars we only have these two
errors left and then
how do we get these six paths so every
time we are filling a cell every time we
are drawing a new arrow we have to keep
in mind how many ways were there before
to go to that path
so that's how we come up with a solution
of six and then there's the fourth step
which is usually the complicated step
construct an optimal solution from the
computed information so we how do we get
our sums back
if we have the six how do i get my sums
out of it what do they look like so i
have to somehow go from the last
position in the table backwards and
figure out all these ways in which my
solution was built up and that's usually
a complicated step so in this kind of
problem here in the money chaining
problem uh in this in this kind of
question i post uh that's not even an
optimization step we are simply simply
following all of the parts but we could
as well say we just want to have the
minimum number of coins to decompose
this
so that sounds great good news everyone
dynamic programming serves optimization
problems over a large that means
exponential search space in a reasonable
amount of time which which means
polynomial so it's tractable by a
computer
but there's a huge but it's not that
easy actually um the development of
successful dynamic programming
recurrences is a matter of experience
talent and luck is what we always said
in our work group so actually it's
really hard to get it right so um this
kind of problem was really small we had
a small table it just was one dimension
so that was kind of easy to see but
imagine the table could be
two-dimensional or even four-dimensional
or we could have multiple tables and
then it just gets really hard
um so how can we alleviate this we came
up with a new way to reason about
dynamic programming and to um yeah even
automate the all the ugly parts of it
so this is going to be great um
how do we do this first of all we will
start with an example
and then we will we will learn that
candidates are trees
questions are algebras and programs are
grammars and then we can also learn
about products which
really give us a lot of power and make
this computations fun
so let's start with an example
live the universe and all the rest
and for this example i want you to
forget everything that you know about
dynamic programming forget everything
forget about the money changing problem
just think we have some magical device
that lets us see at each step how is the
score of our solution of the dynamic
programming problem and how does the
solution that we constructed look like
so we have some magic output device to
see this
and um let's say we just get this
we just get this answer it's 42 we don't
know what it is yet but we can use our
magic device to find out what was the
question what actually happened here
let's do this let's go back one step
oh there's a funny tree so we have a
funny tree which has some match at the
top and then has some outermost children
which say yes and there's a lower score
now which says 28 so what's actually
happening here we don't know yet but we
are going to write it down so we are
going to write down this little equation
um and because it's not that easy to
write down a tree we just write it write
it like this like a formula we write
match
a x a because there's some letter we
don't really care what this letter is it
just seems to be matching so it's the
same letter a
and then there's some x in the middle
which we also don't know yet what it is
but we know what's happening with the
score right we know that there's some
plus 14 going on because before it was
42 and now it's 28.
okay let's go one step further
oh another match appeared and actually
what happened here is we can use the
same equation to write it down so there
seems to be a reoccurring thing we
figured something out and some st is at
the side of some st what's going on
let's go back a few more steps
oh there's something crazy happening now
there's uh there's some divergence going
on there seems to be a choice there's a
maximum going on so we have two
different scores in the left side we
have 14 and the right side we have minus
13.
so there's a choice going on of the
maximum score let's write that down so
we write down in the in the bottom
choice of the maximum score very
interesting so what's going to be
happening in the next step why are these
two numbers different
uh it's actually something different
happening in the both branches now let's
have a look
okay
actually that's true there's two
different things happening so in the
left side there's happening in insertion
and in the right side there's happening
a replacement so we can read now from
the top at these uh trees we can read
there something like st
is going to be matched with str
or in the right side there's stl and str
what's going on that seems very
interesting so we are writing down in
third
and third is happening and cost us minus
two and replace replacement of two
different letters l and r this cost us
minus one
so let's fast forward a bit because we
know now how this works
uh we do a bunch of insertions at once
and we do a bunch of replacements at
once and now we can see actually there's
a string alignment going on there's a
string alignment going on of st
and strange in the left tree and then in
the red tree there's something going on
like saint louis and strange
very interesting and we can see that the
left tree has an overall higher score
and the right tree has a lower score
um and in the same time we can also
again
write down what happened but we can see
the insertion and the replacement it's
still the same as in the previous steps
okay let's do this all the way to the
end
and we can see
saint louis and strange loop we have two
different kind of alignments so first of
all in the left side we had all these
insertions at first and then we have the
two matches there of the lo
which are very important because they
give us a high score so this seems to be
the winner because of these two matches
and in the right side we did all these
replacements and then we did some
insertions and then there's this empty
thing at the end where the alignment
ends
okay very interesting what happened we
found two alignments of saint louis and
strange loop and they are quite
different as i said the um
first one it wins because it has these
two extra matches there and the second
one that loses that's the score of only
15. but what we can see from this or
what we can learn from this is that each
alignment and score are represented by
the same formulas the formulas we've
written down in the process
so let's summarize this reverse
engineering exercise the result of a
dynamic programming algorithm is the
value of a formula which is built from
evaluation functions which are the
functions that take us from the tree to
that number that's yellow
and they are interleaved with
applications of a choice function and
the choice function in our case it was
this maximum function which was
appearing there the maximum function
that selected between the left and the
right tree
and what we can also see is that the
applications of the choice function
seemed to propagate to the top so at the
top we knew that we take this 42 branch
what we also see that formulas are
candidate
solutions with formulas i mean now trees
we can see it as a tree or as a formula
in the way we write it down
and then
input sequences are also part of the
formula so when we read around the
leaves of the tree
we call this the yield and this is
actually the input sequence to my
algorithm
so the two input sequences were strange
loop and st lewis in our case
okay
let's reverse engineer this reverse
engineering
from this we can deduce a procedure how
to solve a dynamic programming problem
so first of all
we said the first step the input
sequence can be found at the leaves
let's do this first we read at first the
input sequence right
and from the input sequence we construct
all candidate solutions as formulas
and then what we do is we move the
applications of the choice function
which was the maximum function down we
push it down inside the formulas as fast
as possible
as far as possible and then
we also evaluate the formulas to get the
desired result so to get our number 42
in our example
candidates are trees what do i mean by
this
let's see
so if we if we think a bit about our
method
several steps of the method can be
automated
the steps of reading in the input
applying the choice function and
evaluating they are always the same so
we could automate them and write a
program to do that
the talents and experience we want to
get rid of the luck
go into constructing of the candidates
constructing of the candidates means how
do i decompose my problem into sub
problems which candidates arise for a
specific given input so how do i
decompose my problem then and also what
does the desired candidate look like
what's a good candidate and what's a bad
candidate what do i want here how do i
score it so the good candidates come up
um and to do this to express the
candidate construction we need some kind
of language for formulas or we could
also say for trees
the good thing is we have such a
language and with this language
constructing candidates can also be
automated that's really great because
this means we get everything for free
except for the creative part where we
think about the decomposition of the
problem and these kind of things
actually we don't get it all for free
because we wrote a compiler to do this
for us and we wrote the third generation
of this compiler so we put a lot of work
into it but you get an idea
okay let's talk about the first building
block of our of our little programming
language that i'm going to show you the
signature
so when we think about the alignment we
wrote down these reoccurring functions
for the replacement deletion insertion
and also the match which i'm going to
include into the replacement from now on
because there's the same number of
arguments
and then there's this empty thing and
the choice function which we also talked
about choice was the maximum for us
right
and this is an abstract description a
description of this so we are saying we
don't know what the answer looks like
but we know it has this kind of form so
we could say the signature is some kind
of data type at the root of every
dynamic programming problem so we could
say
this data type usually we just don't see
it in the normal dynamic programming
approach these candidates are never
represented so we never see this data
type but in our style we can actually
write it down and it helps us
this helps us reason about the problem
so my favorite part questions are
algebras so when i can
can build now my search space because i
have some magic way to describe my
candidates and they are built i don't
know how yet
how do i actually ask a question how do
i say give me please the maximum of this
the maximum scoring alignment for
example
this we can do with evaluation algebras
so this happens in the evaluation phase
what's happening there exactly so
they're happening two things there's the
scoring of the candidates and there's
also the making of choices and these two
things they are all encompassed in an
evaluation algebra which is just a bunch
of functions
functions for scoring and functions for
the choice and one function for the
choice
um
what this is we will see it later
um let's talk about the choice functions
first so in our example from the
beginning
the choice function was the maximum
function right
so we were looking for the maximum
scoring alignment
um and but in fact there's a variety of
choice functions we could come up with
whatever we like
what all of these functions have in
common is that
they map a set they map a list of values
to a list of values which could be in
the end only maybe a list of one value
if we were looking for the maximum
so we can see the maximum it's very
popular
and the minimum it's also very popular
but what happens then if you say i can
give you the best one then comes
somebody from your next office and says
oh give me the five best ones so you
have this max k
which is also very popular
you could also do an enumeration so you
could have the identity function you
just keep everybody this is interesting
to inspect the entire space but could be
very costly because you have to
enumerate them all
and then you can do all kinds of
combinatorics the simplest form would be
just summing up
everything in the entire space
um
also what you could do is sampling and
then it gets really interesting so you
have some random choice from your from
your from your search space
um alright so scores let's talk about
scores squads can also be very versatile
they can be anything so there can be a
distance or similarity between
substructures that's what we use for the
alignment right so we said uh we give it
a similarity score but we could also say
we give it some probabilities if we have
a probabilistic model or we could say we
have the minimum free energy so we have
a thermodynamic model for example when
we want to fold molecules in
bioinformatics we use this
we could also say we just want to see
the candidates what do the candidates
actually look like
if we want to see them as strings or as
trees or just put them as a graphical
representation to put them in our
publication
and then we could just count the
candidates so before printing them or
maybe it makes sense to see how big the
search space is maybe it's too big to
print it out and it's not a good idea
okay how does the scoring of alignments
work
this works with the algebra the scoring
algebra evaluation algebra
and here we see when we look at it we
see
algebra score implements a line so it's
implementing our signature it knows
exactly what functions should be in this
algebra it works only when i when i have
all these functions ready so i have
replacement deletion insertion and empty
and you can see the scoring happens here
and it quite fits what we have seen in
our reverse engineering exercise
and then when we evaluate we could say
we have our formula here this would be
our candidate for 42. i just flatten the
tree for us and shorten the amps because
it wouldn't fit on a slide but you can
read saint louis and
strange loop backwards
and we get 42. so this is something you
can imagine a way we could put it in a
computer like this
okay what's also really great about the
about the algebras the scoring algebras
is they are very versatile and we could
easily have variants of the problem so
we could say we vary our problem we want
to have a fine gap course so if we open
something with an insertion and deletion
in our in one in our alignment so if we
open a gap as we call it
we want to
make it cheaper to open
to extend the gap and
more expensive to open it so it's easier
to have like
one big gap than scattered small gaps
and this could be done by just adding
two extra functions to the algebra so we
would have something like delete extend
and insert extend
and i could also do the same thing if i
wanted to make my alignment local um
so if i don't want to align the entire
string but i could say give me the best
local match in it that means i can
arbitrarily skip something in one of the
strings the input strings so i need
functions for this skip left skip right
or i could combine the two
let's talk about rna
that's my favorite topic that's what i
did my phd on
so this is an rna molecule
um it has several building blocks um
it's a single stranded molecule that
folds back onto itself and forms these
base pairings so you see there there's a
single stranded region in the bottom it
can have biggest there's this big
multi-loop which has many arms there's a
stacking region which is conta
which is entirely made out of base pairs
that stack on each other and then
there's a hairpin loop which is like the
end of the slew
so these are the building blocks of rna
so if i think of
how how would i use this in an algebra
now
let's imagine we just want to print out
this molecule with a string of dots and
brackets so every time we encounter a
single stranded region or something in a
that's not paired we put a dot
and every time we have a base pair we
put the bracket like there's an opening
record for example for this point and
then there's the closing bracket in the
end of the string
uh so how would we do this as an algebra
um
imagine we have for our building blocks
we have functions we abstracted it in a
way so we have sr as our function here
which is the stacking region and we have
hl for hairpin loop and then with these
functions we can say what the what the
algebra actually should do because it
could because it should print out
the molecule in a way of dots and
brackets so we are telling it algebra
pretty we are telling it uh
for the for the first term um
which is the second region we are just
adding a base pair so we're adding a
base pair and then we're going on
recursively and the base pair is just
the pair of brackets and for the hairpin
loop which was the sting with the
looping thing we have a region of
unpaired dots in the middle so we have
the size region construct which is there
in the middle so as we can see we can
use this for for extensive programs and
complicated
problems
and then let's say we just want to count
the rna structures then we actually
don't have to write anything it's very
short the compiler does it for us we can
say i'll run my account out to count
and then
when we evaluate this um we saw that
there's just one folding of it and so
for the counting we would get one
that's just one structure
okay
programs are grammars now uh this is the
last part that's missing right how does
this all work it still doesn't fit
together there's a piece missing
um let's
recapitulate where do we stand
we know now how to represent candidates
we know now how to score and to choose
the candidates we still need to know
which are the candidates for the given
input
for a given problem instance so if i
have a input string how do i get the 3
out of it
and we use we do this using tree
grammars
so i think uh most people here or i hope
most people here are familiar with
string grammars string grammars describe
languages of strings
and from the string grammar we can
automatically derive a parser
which recognizes the strings that are in
the language and then it can say oh the
string is in the language or the string
i reject is not in there
and the tree grammar is actually a
pretty similar thing uh it describes a
language of trees so our candidates are
trees right that's right what we need um
and these trees they have input strings
as their yield sequences remember the
yield sequence was what i read around
the tree
and what we call a yield parser is
something that we can derive
automatically from the grammar
and it reads the yields so it reads the
input string and generates the
corresponding candidate so it's
generating the corresponding tree which
has the right sequence all around the
leaves
how does this work how does this work
how would such a grammar look like
this is again actually a piece of code
which would work with our compiler
and this is a grammar for our alignment
and this looks a bit like the grammar as
you know from theoretical computer
science so there's
so there's an alternative operator we
have these we have this clause here we
have an axiom where we start
um and then in the last line there's
this uh interesting thing h that's the
objective function that's the function
the maximum function from our first
example for example could be any other
function that i want to optimize for but
this is the application of the function
so it's applied to the entire clause
and all these cases replacement deletion
and insertion they are recursive so you
see there's the
alignment it's appearing in there again
so
it's recursive
um
and actually this is how we would write
it in the computer but the way i have it
in my head it looks slightly different
because i think in trees
so
for me it would look like this
so the tree grammar would look like this
i have this one clause which is just the
alignment clause i would have the little
replacement tree deletion tree insertion
tree and empty and in all these little
trees i could plug in another tree and
in this way i could
build a huge tree from it
so now we have all our building blocks
together
with all these building blocks together
we have a evaluation signature which we
call sigma we have a tree grammar which
we call g over sigma and we have a
concrete evaluation algebra which we can
call a with an objective function h with
all these parts together
i can make an algebraic dynamic
programming algorithm
the thing that i can feed into my
compiler and then it just works
but wait what is this thing satisfying
vermont's principle
let's look into this
so vermont's principle of optimality
it's actually really really important
this is the thing why dynamic
programming works
so
richard berman in 1964
the father of dynamic programming said
an optimal solution can be composed
solely from optimal solutions to
sub-problems
interesting
so if i think about this for a minute in
my own words i would say something like
moving the choice function around in the
formula should not affect the final
result list
that means i can
if i have the i if i have the optimal
results and i combine them it will
always be optimal again so where i
choose it doesn't really matter i could
push it down in my tree
the interesting thing is that this is a
requirement it's not a theorem so we
have to prove it
we can prove this by proving the
distributivity over the choice function
of the choice function over the scoring
function
but actually for a maximum and stuff
like that it just holds
okay there's one last part we have to
talk about to uh
to understand how this all works that's
the phase amalgamation part
so um imagine we have given all our
parts the grammar the algebra and the
input string
we can just evaluate it and we get some
value three so let's for example say we
are folding r and a we are looking for
how many base pairs are in the folded
results and we get the result of three
so if we think about how this works in
our conceptual review in our head we
would say first of all there's this
yield passing going on and it's
constructing the space of candidates of
all the trees my search space and then
there's the second space a second phase
where all these trees they are
transformed into numbers and then there
we choose the best one but actually
that's not true actually that's not true
because it would be way too slow in
reality both of these phases are merged
to make dynamic programming possible and
to make it fast so we as soon as we
constructed everything that's necessary
we we pick the optimal thing and we only
keep that
that's why it's fast
so
let's talk about products
we first revisit again where do we stand
we can now describe algorithms on an
abstract level
we can now generate correct and
efficient code where the compiler does
it
we can independently vary the tree
grammar or the evaluation algebra so we
could plug in another algebra if we
wanted to
and we can run one analysis at a time
but how about doing several analysis at
the time wouldn't that be great so for
example if we could compute the best
best score of the alignment and then
print the best scoring candidate we
could actually look at the alignment
what does it look like at the same time
wouldn't that be great
or we could even ask a more difficult
question so let's say we compute the
best rna structure for each different
abstract shape so let's say one shape
has three arms and one shape has two
arms
what does the best rna structure for
each of the shapes look like
like with the maximum number of base
pairs for example
this we can do with products of algebras
so we define something which is the
product operator
we just call it star here um and we can
give it two algebras and we get a new
algebra out of it
and what does it do it suddenly computes
uh
pairs of answers
and it uses and it does this using just
the functions which are the algebra
functions from the two algebras that i
put in so it's combining the two algebra
functions that i put in
component-wise and then
it's choosing in a dependent way so it's
choosing first according to the first
objective and then according to the
second objective
um
the intuitive understanding of this how
does this work we would again think
there's two phases going on so first of
all we compute all the candidates via
the
algebra functions and then we apply this
objective function h in the end but in
reality it's the same thing as we talked
about before
these phases are all interleaved it's
all happening at the same time but we
can write it down in this uh really nice
way um and all separate just because we
came up with this
formulation of it so that's a real
luxury to write it in this way
um what's also great about it is we
don't have to do any extra programming
we don't have to do any extra debugging
we just have to make sure that our
combined algebra still satisfies
barman's principle
so now we can do very many fun things
with products because they are very
powerful
so for example we could look if we are
solving an optimization problem we we
could look at the number of co-optimal
solutions so we are looking at all the
best solutions for example for example
when we're looking at the number of base
pairs we could count them so
how many of the structures have three
base pairs how many of the predicted
structures have four base fares or
things like that so we can get an
overview of the entire space so that's
very interesting
um what's also great is the second point
uh the easy candidate output so it's
easy to
see at the same time the candidate so
the backtracking step we suddenly get it
for free so if we look at the base pairs
for example and then we print what does
the actual folding look like like at
this as this string of dots and brackets
as we are used to seeing it we can
actually see what does the folding look
like with that best result
so we don't have to do the backtracking
um
what's also really nice is the something
we call classified dynamic programming
that's a bit like combining the previous
ideas so for example we could
ask a question where the first algebra
is just separating our search space into
into classes or into different spaces so
for example we could say we take the
folding space with all the folded
molecules in it and we want to separate
it by a shape and then we want to count
how many of these different shapes are
in each of these groups so we could do
something like this with a shape star
count one
and then what we could also do is we
could ask for each of the shape groups
which one of the of the structures is
the best one which one has the most base
pairs for example
what it's also really useful for is for
ambiguity checking so if you want to
check our grammar if it's if it's built
in a good way this can be really useful
so we can do just something like pretty
print the
result pretty print the candidate and
then count it and it should be always
one if it appears twice we did something
wrong when we constructed our grammar so
we could work on that
um
and also we can do sampling so we have
some other kinds of products which i
have no time to talk about today
unfortunately but then it gets really
powerful because we can sample if the
space is too big uh we can sample from
it or we can of course do products of
products we can see this is a powerful
technique
um so using algebraic dynamic
programming as we call it we developed a
bunch of tools so this is not just
theory this is actually working the
compiler is working
and we develop many tools with it so it
is just a bunch of bioinformatics tools
that we
that we developed mostly they are in
rna structure prediction and alignment
um but this is not the only only
problems you could solve with it so we
solved other problems with it like the
optimal matrix chain multiplication for
example or the satisfiability problem so
it's not it's not restricted to
bioinformatics i and i encourage you to
bring me your own problems
um
so let's recapitulate what's cool about
algebraic dynamic programming why do we
want to do this
so we have a bunch of advantages that we
have seen
our work is reduced to the creative
aspects so all these horrible parts like
the table axis and
whoever implemented dynamic programming
algorithms knows who what i'm talking
about you have to fiddle with index
indices of tables all the time we don't
have to do it the compiler is doing it
which is a great relief
and we have time to explore our ideas
rather than debugging this
code
which is really great we can focus on
this creative part
we create reusable and reliable
components so all these algebras we can
plug them in and out we can have
different address that just give us the
output or count or whatever
for the same grammar and
this is completely composable
we turn tricks into techniques there's a
lot of trickery in dynamic programming
in the conventional way
and we make dynamic programming easier
to learn i think we just have more more
words now to reason about it and take
all these parts apart
and talk about them separately
disadvantages are of course textbooks
still use old-fashioned recurrences i
had to dig to
through many pages of recurrences in my
phd
um
another disadvantage is limited to
sequence like data
and the problems they decompose into
sub-word-like structures that's why it's
so useful in bioinformatics but i think
it can be applied in other
in other areas too and actually this
limitation is just now in the compiler
but in theory already worked it out it's
way more powerful than that
um
yeah that's all i had to say today so
i'm thanking my work group
the practic practical computer science
group in betaflight where where i
learned about these things
and i worked on the compiler
and remember the reverse engineering of
482 and talk to me about your favorite
dynamic programming problem so i want
you if you are interested in dynamic
programming
to come to me and
i would like to to try to get it to work
with our compiler to see more problems
and see what's possible
so thank you all for your attention